تطوير مستمر للمناطق السعوديه
واستراتيجيات ضخمه وشامله لكل منطقه اليوم
اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن تاسيس المكتب الاستراتيجي لتطوير
منطقه الحدود الشماليه لرفع مستوى التنميه
المستدامه وتعزيز جوده الحياه لسكانها
وزوارها بالاضافه لايجاد بيئه استثماريه
جاذبه لرؤوس الاموال وتوفير فرص عمل
لابناء المنطقه المكتب الاستراتيجي لتطوير
منطقه الحدود الشماليه سيعمل على استثمار
المقومات الاقتصاديه والطبيعيه والتاريخيه
في المنطقه
وتحتضن منطقه الحدود الشماليه مخزونا ضخما
من الفوسفات يعادل 7% من مخزون الفوسفات
العالمي
وتشغل المنطقه مساحه قدرها 133 الف كيلو
متر مربع من مساحه السعوديه ويسكنها 400
الف نسمه وتسهم بمقدار 27 مليار ريال في
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
وينضم الينا هنا في استوديو نشره الرابعه
عن ابامير منطقه الحدود الشماليه ورئيس
اللجنه الاشرافيه للمكتب الاستراتيجيه
الامير سعود بن عبد الرحمن بن ناصر سمو
الامير حياك الله
نورتنا الله يحفظك احنا اسعد سمو الامير
اسال اولا عن اهميه تاسيس هذا المكتب
الاستراتيجي بالنسبه لكم لتطوير منطقه
الحدود الشماليه كيف يمكن الحديث عنه في
البدايه ارفع لمقام خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ايده الله والى
سيدي صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء اسماء ايات الشكر والعرفان على
تاسيس المكتب الاستراتيجي لتطوير منطقه
الحدود الشماليه ولا شك ان الاعلان عن
تاسيس اول مكتب استراتيجي لتطوير المنطقه
يعكس اهتمام سمو العهد في تنميه جميع
مناطق ومدري المملكه المكتب الاستراتيجي
لتطوير منطقه حدود الشماليه
سوف يعمل على نقل المنطقه
الى مستوى تنموي متقدم ومستدام يستهدف
المكتب الاستراتيجي لتطوير منطقه الحدود
الشماليه التوظيف الامثل للمميزات النسبيه
التي تتمتع بها مدن ومحافظات الحدود
الشماليه سموك السؤال ايضا عن اسهام تاسيس
هذا المكتب الاستراتيجي تحديدا لتطوير
المنطقه الحدود الشماليه في دعم التنميه
التوظيف انعكاس واثر على على ابناء
المنطقه ايضا المنطقه كما تعلم تتميز
بمقومات اقتصاديه وطبيعيه وامكانات بشريه
مميزه مثل هذه الفرصه تحتاج الى استثمارات
نوعيه باشراف حكومي يتفهم احتياجات القطاع
الخاص وهذا احد الادوار المرتقبه للمكتب
ولا شك ان خلق المشروعات المستدامه سينعكس
ايجابيا على المنطقه وعلى الاقتصاد الوطني
من خلال رفع مساهمه المنطقه في الناتج
المحلي والتوسع في خلق الوظائف لابناء
وبنات المنطقه ايضا اسمه الامير ايضا
السؤال عن هذا المكتب كيف سيساهم في
مكتبه التطوير طبعا في خلق مشروعات تنمويه
نوعيه تعظم الاستفاده من الامكانات التي
تمتلكها منطقه الحدود الشماليه دور المكتب
هو العمل على وضع التوجه التنموي للمنطقه
من خلال الاستفاده من المزايا النسبيه في
المنطقه مثل الخامات
والتعدين وابرزها الفوسفات
بالاضافه الى وجود المراعي الطبيعيه
والمواقع
والموقع الحدودي المتميز وتحويل هذه
المزايا الى مبادرات ومشاريع نوعيه من
خلال رؤيه تنمويه شامله تساهم في تطوير
المنطقه وتوفير فرص الاستثمار سمو الامير
الاثر التنموي المتوقع لهذا المكتب بعد
انشائه الاثر على تطوير المنطقه كيف يمكن
النظر اليه المكتب يستهدف التوسع في
التنميه في تنميه المنطقه
ودعم القطاعات التنمويه التي تميز المنطقه
من خلال ايجاد فرص استثماريه واعره
ومستدامه بالعمل مع القطاع الخاص
والارتقاء بالخدمات والمشروعات
للمنطقه ووضع معايير قياس لاداء الاجهزه
الحكوميه
والقطاعات المختلفه كما ان ايجاد هذا
المكتب الاستراتيجي يعد نقله
نوعيه واقتصاديه مهمه للمنطقه لتشمل تنميه
كل مدن ومحافظات ومراكز المنطقه باشرت
سموكم الى كثير من الميزات اللي ما شاء
الله تمتلكها منطقه الحدود الشماليه اريد
ان اسال عن مجمل هذه الميزات كيف يمكن
النظر اليها سمو الامير منطقه الحدود
الشماليه تمثل اقصى شمال المجاور للدول
وابرزها منفذ جديده عرعر مع جمهوريه
العراق الشقيقه حيث بات المنفذ نقطه اتصال
مهمه للركاب القادمين الى المملكه وكذلك
للتبادل التجاري حيث يبلغ متوسط معدل
النمو للتبادل التجاري بين المملكه
والعراق خلال الفتره من الربع الثاني من
عام 2017 حتى الربع الثاني من عام 2021
حوالي 12.8%
من التبادل التجاري بين البلدين كما اسهم
اكتشاف خامل فوسفات
بكميات تجاريه بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه الى
تعزيز المناخ
الاستثماري وتعزيز الاقتصاد الوطني
بالدرجه الاولى خلال تنويع مصادر الدخل
الامر الذي حفز الى تدشين مشروع مدينه وعد
الشمال ما هي رسالتكم التي توجهون الى
القطاع الخاص
كما قلت القطاع الخاص هو ركيزه وشريك
اساسي في التنميه وتاسيس المكتب
الاستراتيجي لتطوير منطقه الحدود الشماليه
سوف يجسر العلاقه مع هذا القطاع وهو في
الحقيقه امام فرصه استثماريه ضخمه في
القطاعات الزراعيه والحيوانيه والصناعيه
والتعدين فضلا عن الفرص السياحيه الهائله
التي لم تشتغل
وعموم القطاعات الترفيهيه والرياضات
النوعيه بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء الله شكرا
جزيلا لحضورك معي في نشره الرابعه كان
معنا هنا نائب امير منطقه الحدود الشماليه
ورئيس اللجنه الاشرافيه للمكتب
الاستراتيجي الامير سعود بن عبد الرحمن بن
ناصر شكرا لك الله يسلمك